declarative programming languages
have several advantages
over traditional languages
for example
programs in such languages
are considerably shorter
than equivalent programs
in imperative languages
here for example
is a program in C
and here is the equivalent program
in Erlang
(phone rings)
Hello
Hello, Joe
Hello, Mike
Question
does anyone care about
the differences between
declarative and imperative languages anymore?
don’t be silly
the declarative/imperative debate
is always a crowd pleaser
from what I can tell
kids these days are going with what’s cool
like Node.js and Ruby on Rails
let’s ask Robert
(phone rings)
hello, Robert?
hello, Mike
Joe’s back to talking about
declarative languages again
I just think Erlang’s got a problem
when its spokesman
is an old fuddy-duddy
eh Joe?
bite me
Robert, what do you think?
Erlang’s the shizzah!
but I can’t blame kids
for picking something a little less
crusty
Erlang’s image is stuck in the 1980s
It’s the Bananarama of languages
okay
tell you what
this is bullshit
if kids these days
don’t want to use Erlang
which is the real
rock star tech
then fuck it
I’ll turn this video off
and go home
take my nine nines
with me
(video off)
Joe
I didn’t mean anything by it
yeah Joe
Mike was just
trying to be constructive
Joe
turn the video back on
I won’t
I won’t have Erlang disparaged!
yo yo yo
I can totally help you geezers
who said that?
all Erlang needs
is an image upgrade
that’s very interesting.
lots of things
from the 80s are cool
just look at
Fraggle Rock
and Super Mario Brothers
what the hell is that
it’s one of those
Ruby hipsters
watch it grandpa
just because I carry my Mac
in a messager bag
and have great taste in nose rings
doesn’t mean I use Ruby
I for one
and interested in
what the little girl
has to say
yo, whatever
first we have to fix the name
a language named after
a nineteenth century
Danish mathematician
is about as cool
as having a Facebook account
it’s just like the olden days
when Erlang was banned
we had to change the name
that’s right
when Erlang fell out of fashion
at Ericsson
we changed the name
to OTP
three of the trendiest names
we could think of
Open
Telecom
Platform
gives me the chills
just thinking about it
okay
that’s bullcrap
no one care about
telecom platforms
we need something fresh
something edgy
like Erlang on Rails
Jesus Christ
The last thing you want to do
is imitate
no. something original.
how about
Erlang++?
I got it
we keep OTP
but with a hip
edgy twist
check it
your language
will hereby be known as
Outlaw
Techno
Psychobitch
it does spell OTP
don’t know what it has to do
with software
what do you think
Joe?
I absolutely love it
that name is fucking gangster
yeah, Joe
you rule
okay
next thing we need
is a video that is
just as cool as
the original Erlang The Movie
but speaks to today’s
programmer hipster
I’m thinking something
like this
yo, what up bitches
Rex here
this time
I’m talking about
a bad ass
new language
called Outlaw Techno Psychobitch
or OTP for short
so you all know
I’m a huge Ruby fan
Ruby gives you 15 ways
to do the same thing
and freedom of choice is good
then I realized
that’s just 15 different ways
to create really slow
crappy programs
then I started using Node.js
I like Node because
as my hero Ryan Dahl says
it’s like coloring with crayons
and playing with Duplo blocks
but as it turns out
it’s less like
playing with Duplo blocks
and more like
playing with slinkies
slinkies that get tangled together
and impossible to separate
so then I checked out
Outlaw Techno Psychobitch
It’s a language out of Sweden
that can be used to build web scale,
asynchronous,
non-blocking,
sharded,
event-driven,
message passing,
NoSQL,
reliable,
highly available,
high performance,
real-time,
clusterable,
bad ass,
rock star,
get the girls,
get the boys
impress your mom,
impress your cat
applications
Ryan Dahl
my hero says
we should not be supporting
more programming languages
that we should be killing them
that all these bullshit
projects are confusing people
but Psychobitch is just
so damn cool
I couldn’t resist
giving it a try
the first thing
Psychobitch kills off
is curly braces
thank God
after a half century of
curly braces
we need something that’s fresh
Psychobitch uses single character
block delimiters
like in sentences
my hero Ryan Dahl says
math is not necessary
that people who think
it’s superior to curly braces
are wrong
but, I figure
if math can get a rover
to Mars
maybe it can help us
write better programs
Psychobitch gets
pretty uptight about logic
if you say
that X is one
and then turn around
and say X is two
Psychobitch goes ape shit
she’s like
what the hell
when did one start equalling two?
Psychobitch has this great feature
called pattern matching
you define the patterns
and if there’s a match
your program keeps going
if something doesn’t match
it crashes
like assertions but built-in
what happens when your program crashes?
Psychobitch has you covered
it monitors your code
and restart things that break
it’s like the Terminator
you can blast it in the face
with a shot gun
it stops for a second
then keeps on coming
I’ve written a chat server
in Psychobitch
it’s where all my friends and me
can chat about how awesome
Ryan Dahl is
because the server is written in Psychobitch
it can easily handle
thousands of concurrent users
shit
did I say thousands
because I meant
tens of thousands
and by tens of thousands
I mean
hundreds of thousands
I’m already logged in as myself
at the top
I’ll log in as another user
you say something using the “tell” command
the messages are received instantly
even though there are
hundreds of thousands of connected users
I’ll use the “yell” command
to broadcast a message to every user
that literally sent the message
to 300,000 users
about a second
okay
300,000 concurrent users is impressive
but even Node.js can do that
let’s try something hard
to make things interesting
we’ll trigger a bug
on the server
damn
I must have said something bad
but as you can see
Mary and Jack can still chat
of the 300,000 users on the server
I’m the only one affected
let’s see
if we can fix the bug
here’s the code
holy crap
it looks like
the original programmer
in his zeal
added some forbidden utterances
let’s clean this up
because we don’t want to censor
okay
I recompiled the code
next, I’ll reload it
in real time
with 300,000 concurrent chats going on
done
in case you missed it
here it is again
in slow motion
for some of you
what you just saw
is not self explanatory
if gracefully handling bugs
with hundreds of thousands of
concurrent sessions
and fixing them in real time
without stopping the server
seems passe
you can aways use Ruby
then, when your app doesn’t scale
move to Node.js
then, when you can’t maintain your code
because it’s a pile of tangled slinkies
move to Psychobitch
with that experience
you can appreciate what you just saw
for the rest of you
yes
that just happened
So
what do you guys think about Psychobitch?
she’s utterly terrifying
it makes me wonder if perhaps
Psychobitch is a real person
you mean
is the name based on my experience
with a girlfriend who’s bat shit crazy
drop dead gorgeous
brilliant
and brags to her friends
about costing me
tens of thousands of dollars
in therapy
over the last three years
oh shit
I know a girl like that
she scarred me for life
literally
seriously
I’ll show you the scars